will up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar in I'm back at it again to
discuss the latest developments and the
also exciting one piece story if you
enjoyed these one piece reviews and want
to keep them coming the best thing you
can do is smash that like button and
share this video with a friend if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future one piece reviews keep in
mind there will be spoilers in this
video we are talking about the latest
Lumpy's chapter chapter 976 after all
the cover for the Shonen Jump magazine
is epic this week it includes Luffy
sharing a drink with Goldie Roger and
Odin talk about a high cover Luffy is
clearly in good company a company of
kings after all all these guys possess
conquers hockey which represents having
the qualities of a king Odin was the
rightful ruler of guano roger was the
pirate king and as we know and as is
being suggested here Luffy will also
become a king the king of the Pirates
alright enough of me gushing over to
cover let's jump to the chapter this
chapter is called allow me to introduce
myself suggesting that someone will show
up in this chapter who isn't already
there
as usual keep the chapter name in mind
as we go on since it shall be relevant
we're told that kena moon achieved a
feat despite himself referring to how he
accidentally misread Yahoo's message and
as a result gave the wrong information
to his close friends in doing so
conjurer the trader gave the wrong info
to Orochi the skin Aman kept or og from
destroying their forces by making him
believe they were at another port last
chapter was hilarious and keen Amon
played it off like he planted the whole
time but his samurai friends know him
too well they tried to make him fess up
that he actually misread the message he
naman admits that he got lucky he says
that he might die today in battle
because he's just used up a life's worth
of luck here all this pointing fun at
the fact that the whole kingdom won't
accidentally trick encontró situation
was insanely lucky and suggesting that
from here on out they can't rely too
much on luck in the fight to come his
fellow samurai remind King Hamad
that he's their leader so he's spending
all of their luck as well not just his
own they're telling him that they are
all in it together come what may one for
all all for one and if Kingdom one
out of luck and eyes they will to
Kinnaman is clearly touched but he plays
it off in order to deflect the sappiness
of the moment then kena moon looks
determined and proclaims that whatever
his fate is he will accept it I love
that these guys don't know what's gonna
happen they are well aware that they are
probably walking towards their death
they're gonna take on two yong KO after
all however they are ready for death and
following dangerous advice kena moon
raises his sword into the air
proclaiming to everyone that they're
going to dispel the humiliation done to
Odin and change the face of Juan oh the
hype is real kena moon is the man and
this moment really highlights a how
brave these guys are and be how high the
stakes are they're risking their lives
for Odin's memory and for the future
Ilana the beast pirate extras think they
can do something because they have a
warship while our guys just have boats
somehow our feeling that things won't go
according to their plan but finally we
go to conjure remember he's kidnapped
momonosuke and I was wondering what's
gonna happen with that
well someone save mo monoski or what
Komatsu
is the one who steps up remember he's a
fish man and so he goes through a stormy
sea water like it's nothing as he's
swimming we get news that the beast
pirates couldn't contact onigashima
because the banquet is holding them up
the banquet for Kaito and big mom oh man
they're so close to the uncle and that's
got me unbearably hyped up right now
Komatsu shoes from the water at chondral
keep in mind kalamazoo is super strong
he was one of the nine scabbards along
with danger and a Shana who was singled
out by ki naman as being especially
strong but Kandra blocks his blade with
his giant ink brush then kundrot uses a
drawing of what looks like a giant crane
to fly away after escaping with Moomin
escape from Kalamazoo he tells him that
he will also find he ot and kill her
since he knows she's alive now koa
matzos face understandably looks
tortured Komatsu took care of he OD in
the past and went hungry so she could
eat he loves her like she was his own
child and now this dude who just
betrayed them in kidnap momonosuke
says he'll kill her at this point you
gotta hate chondral yes obviously
his backstory was tragic but he was
friends with these guys longer than the
newest parents and they had nothing to
do with their deaths
especially momen nosegay and he OD
they're completely innocent
not only is Kandra betraying them now
he's even rubbing it in as much as
possible despite has passed we badly
want to see him get his just desserts
now he number one is funny and points
out how control lied to them about being
a bad draw for our samurai kundrot just
true rotten and not so helpful designs
well he could have been drawing
masterpieces that helped them out way
more now that we know about control
skill with his devil through powers he's
much more of a threat than he was before
woman no scheme mentions that he's
scared of how high they are
while control tells everyone present
that they aren't threats Tokaido and
that they won't even make it to the
island you could say that moment escape
is not being a very manly leader here
because he begs to be put down
cries about how scared he is and begs
someone to help him in his defense
though he's only eight years old so even
if it ended at that point you gotta cut
him some slack we see Luffy confused
about the whole situation
he asks Kanjar ro and momonosuke where
they're going he still doesn't know the
conjurer was a spy the whole time
sangeun robbing though are quick to
catch on that country was the spy then a
shot chopper tells a shock luffy that
kundrot is indeed the spy who saab says
that he'll snipe Kandra down but an ink
cloud begins to form as Kinnaman points
out it's another technique that Kandra
has been keeping to himself chondros
low-key very skilled
what follows is another show of his
power but by no means should we assume
that he doesn't have more equally
effective tricks up his sleeves the
clouds rain down ink arrows countless of
them come down they hurt people and
destroy ships Momo knows he is still
crying again all he can do is beg conjul
to stop so that everyone doesn't die
however that's exactly what conjurer
wants he wants everyone to die along
with Odin and he tells that to monoski
own and son Oda is doing a great job of
really making us hate conjurer here you
can bet that when our boys get their
revenge it's gonna be extremely
satisfying after all this buildup in
middle of all this action there's some
time for humor as Sanji jumps with an
exaggerated expression in order to
protect Nami no matter what's going on
you can be sure that Sanji will be true
to his sympa
Kandra keeps on rubbing salt on the
wound telling mama knows k that his dead
mom just prolonged everyone's suffering
by using her time-travel powers to
dangle hope in front of everyone while
only extending their time of death by 20
years then he says that the general of
those hearty samurai referring to momen
escape is a cowardly kid who's afraid of
heights he laughs at that at how they
expect someone who's such a coward to
rule over a country but mama knows
commands up here this is definitely
gonna be one of his defining moments in
retrospect he says that he knows better
than anyone that he's not his father
keep in mind
Odin is an absolute legend that's
something that the flashback chapters
helped to establish he's the closest
thing wana had to a gol D Roger
expecting an eight-year-old kid to live
up to that is not fair and mama knows he
has been carrying that weight despite
his fear he tells everyone to not worry
about him
rather than helplessly waiting for
someone to save him the crying moment
nosegay promises to get out of this
difficult situation on his own he knows
that it might be impossible for him to
escape but he's willing to at the age of
8 sacrifice himself for a greater cause
he tells them to go defeat orochy and
Kaito and to protect wha no this speech
brings his followers to tears and even
Luffy is impressed saying that little
Momo behaves like a man momo nosegay
will turn out to be a manly leader yet
it seems then we get a beautiful moment
of Luffy being Luffy not caring about
social standing whatsoever he calls
wonho's rightful ruler a poor whiny kid
as he compliments his speech in the
process Luffy completely unwittingly
upsets one of those case followers but
Luffy ignores them and goes on to tell
mo monoski to survive Luffy promises
that if he can do that he'll come and
save him since they're friends after all
mama knows he is touched and agrees
putting on a strong face despite his
tears and snotty nose and he is brave
brave is not an absence of fear but
doing the right thing
in spite of fear and that's exactly what
mama knows skate did despite only being
8 and feeling a lot of fear he
prioritized his country to himself and
you can't help but respect that it's not
about tears it's about not letting tears
stop you and moment loss k didn't in the
process he gave his people a huge morale
boost feeling that energy Luffy wants to
leave immediately for onigashima some
people are wounded and some ships are
unusable after chondros pink arrow
attack so they want to hurry up and get
to the island before any more problems
pop up the last thing they want is to
die at sea before the real battle even
begins the scabbards reunite and even
Shinobu is there now freed of chondros
surprisingly powerful snakes she
apologizes for not protecting moment
dose k well enough Tina mone is just
glad that she's safe and assumes that
the enemy will keep momonosuke alive for
a while to rise o meanwhile asks den
Gino what happened to his face it's a
little moment and the words being
exchanged are not as important as the
fact that these comrades are finally
together again then judo included law
being his usual serious self tells them
that his ship is not a hotel for samurai
while they thank him for his hospitality
this interaction is hilarious and laws
beautifully frustrated with these guys
he wants to get the business just as the
other supernova kid wants to kids not
gonna stay behind Luffy and tells his
men to get ahead of the straw hats he
wants to lead I really appreciate this
epic 3 supernova Alliance keep in mind
these are the supernova captains with
the highest bounties as far as we know
so it's just a dream team with Zorro and
probably killer both supernovas
themselves being thrown into the mix -
and I just love Kidd as a character as
well I think he's a very interesting
character foil to the pure-hearted Luffy
just then long-range cannons fire at
them one beef ship isn't beat yet and
they are using technology of all things
to attack aw technology the weak man's
haki
but in all seriousness it's interesting
how technology does play a significant
role in one piece to the point where you
can create strong pacifist does enhance
a strong warrior like kuma and even
create artificial devil fruits here we
have high
quality weapons entering the mix in the
form of cannons Kaito has factories that
produce high quality weapons and they're
nothing to sneeze at now these guys are
significantly far away and can hit our
dudes while our dudes seemingly are too
far to hit them back we get another
three panel split of the supernova
captains again giving us some great
contrast and insight into their
different personalities law beats
himself up for being too careless he
should have been smarter Luffy doesn't
think about the past he just wants to
solve the problem by ramming into it he
just wants to go maximum speed straight
ahead Kidd the most funny is the only
one breaking into a smile and saying
that a few samurai ships sinking is not
his problem
he's so unapologetic about not caring
that it's funny then journal notices
that the ship is keeping its distance
while firing so it keeps sinking more
ships if they can't close the distance
all the boats will sink before they get
to Onaga Shima
and just as the Beast pirates are
confident of victory Bank something goes
straight through their [ __ ] destroying
it there are speculations as to what's
happening is it the work of ghost babies
Musab however believes that ghost babies
will attack in a more peaceful way so it
can't be ghost babies another hilarious
convo right in the middle of the hype
someone is standing there but who who
saved them he introduces himself as a
fish man and as a new recruit of the
straw hats showing how important being a
straw hat has become to his identity of
course it is djembe the night of the sea
who stayed to fight with the Sun pirates
in order to help them survive and to
help the straw hats get away from big
moms crew he survived that he's back in
all of his epic former warlord glory and
the reaction of the other supernova
captain's is amazing because anyone even
big mom would love to have the 438
million bounty jimbe as part of their
crew but luffy gets the honor and the
others are somewhere between disbelief
and jealousy law is just like no way
while cain is openly shocked a priceless
reaction as promised jimbe the helmsman
of the straw hat pirates has come back
to his captain alive right in time for
battle Luffy's ecstatic with stars in
his eyes at seeing jimbe and the
rest of the straw hats are excited too
you can feel their love through the page
and having the crew together is the
cherry on top of the hype cake that will
be this upcoming battle so glad to see
the O so powerful djembe make his return
when you think about it every pirate
crew since they spend so much time at
sea should have at least one fish man on
their crew if not more they're insanely
useful and powerful at sea and Jinbei is
just the best and that is it for this
chapter of you momonosuke became a man
Jim Bay returned and we got more of Kidd
which is always awesome the last ship
threat has been dealt with and we are
ready to get to the island in the next
chapter where the big mom pirates and
beast pirates should be banqueting we're
so so close to what is sure to be an
epic climax of this arc let me know what
you think is gonna happen in the next
chapter how will the initial meeting
between our guys and the yong-chol go
down if you enjoyed this review make
sure to smash that like button and share
this video with a friend if you haven't
be sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future One Piece reviews I've been
making more one piece videos so leave
recommendations for videos you would
like to see in the comments a special
thank you goes out to our patrons over
on patreon who help us survive YouTube
issues and help make videos like this
one possible first and foremost I want
to thank the legend acknowledge my lord
we go sent by sama himself baby ray and
the one tear patrons the ones will stay
on the top all clans Steven grata
Aloha attempt the world stealers the
school bus Tyson cariño a choir respect
and Pattaya Haifa and our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson King
zelgius Anatoly kazansky angel Cruz team
Sparky 65 Rohan Kapoor cricket XP Ted no
Ted Joel - Joel Stanton very Gucci
Elisha actor animal 69 Jessica Calif on
emperor otaku JCCC waka and the coach
thank you all so much if you enjoy our
work you can support more of it by going
over to patreon calm anime uproar and
becoming a patron today for as little as
one dollar if you do so you'll get named
feature in future videos alongside these
amazed
chasing people right here and you'll
even get access to our private patron
only discord where we talk about anime
life and of course the dank memes so
check out patreon calm an Amir
wink in the description if you're
interested you can also now join the
YouTube channel and support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see you space Cowboys
[Music]